hey guys welcome to vlog university
thank you so much for all of your
amazing submissions from last week which
was themed and video games now before we
get into your submissions from last week
I mean even guys your homework
assignment and that is to create a video
of yourself as a baby here's the video
with me as a baby
might have some videos you might have
some photos but either way take those
videos to take those photos put them
together to make a video and add it as a
video response here that's how you guys
turn in your homework assignment okay so
now let's check out some of the videos
that you guys created for last week's
episode of vlog University which was
themed video games that you guys didn't
know I actually have a video gaming
channel here on YouTube I play video
games and talk about it I understand why
do we need these hearts do I have it
should I take it with me hmm I think
like I have to first up is one of my
favorites by green garden hose now this
video is Mario trying to go on vacation
but as you can see he kind of keeps
getting a little lost
now this video is absolutely hilarious
it's a spoof of Fred playing call of
duty black ops and let me tell you what
if you never play black ops you've never
seen Fred you're still gonna think this
video is funny now how about some
stop-motion Mario oh it's that you want
some more shot motion great because
here's the space invader by the flame
Falcon
check out this big back ache burger who
had a sidescrolling Paper Mario like not
the game Paper Mario like legit like
pieces of paper it's made out of paper
crayons and markers and paper
I'm not much of a sports gamer but Mikey
J created an almost exact replica of me
in Tiger Woods PGA of big pot 55 put
himself in doodle jump and cut the rope
on the iPhones pretty sweet thanks again
for all of your amazing submissions this
week and I look forward to checking out
all of the great stuff that you guys
create this week for the theme of babies
you as a baby just add it as a video
response to this video to be included in
a chance to be in the next episode of
log University thank you again and be
sure to click Subscribe up here so
you'll know when I launch my next
episode of diversity or some other
random thing that I plan on putting on
this channel oh yeah and I check out the
rest of my YouTube channels here wow so
fast so fast alright that's it I look
forward to seeing a lot of you guys
playlist live
that's it so it's got for you stop
talking now distinguish